[music playing]
You know, just about
every car guy has found
themselves in this
position, man, that Brann
has found himself in.
His Cadillac, Twinkletoes,
needed some work done on it.
He found a guy, laid
out a pile of money.
Car's in no better shape
than it was before.
So he brought the car to us.
We can't go back in
time and fix the old,
but we can certainly
fix this Cadillac
and make it gorgeous
just like Brann wanted.
I know he was a
little nervous handing
the car over again
to another shop, man,
but this baby is beautiful.
And he's here today to get
reunited with Twinkletoes.
Ryan, my man, bring
out Twinkletoes!
[music playing]
Oh-ho, even from the front!
Ho-ho!
[laughing]
Oh, damn!
Oh, [bleep]!
Oh, my god!
DANNY (VOICEOVER):
Brann's Cadillac was
a really great car that
just had some bad luck, man.
We took that blue base, stripped
it down, and started all over.
After straightening
out the body,
Ryan created a paint design
that would make this Caddy
dazzle with extreme pimpness.
We freshened up that
engine and transmission
and added new brakes and
suspension components.
Polly went crazy on the custom
blue and white zodiac interior
and the vinyl top.
Lastly, the etched windshield in
tribute to Brann's manager Nick
on the trunk lid put this
project over the top.
I absolutely love how
this car turned out, man.
This ride is cool, clean,
and fit for a rock star.
[stuttering]
My mind is absolutely blown.
This is insane.
Oh, dude.
There he is.
Very controversial.
Let's talk about
that for a sec
while we got you right here.
Yeah, that's my
boy, Nick John.
One of our best
friends, our manager.
Just one of our very,
very closest friends.
Unfortunately, passed away,
like, a week and a half ago.
So sorry for that loss.
Yeah.
And so I said, man, it
would be the coolest tribute
to have one of his catchphrases
that everybody that
knows him and loves him knows--
very controversial-- put
on the car somewhere.
So that looks
absolutely perfect,
and it just warms
my heart to see it.
And so happy that I'll be able
to take him to the restaurant
too.
Keep him with
you all the time.
Yeah, all the time.
And Ryan-- jeez!
[laughing]
Dude.
This car.
I have to give props
to the body shop,
because this is
not a little car.
This is not like a Chevette.
This is, like, 10 miles
of car altogether.
Yeah, that's about--
I think about 20 feet of steel.
And this sucker is straight.
The body lines are sharp
enough to cut your arms off.
So sick!
- Uh-huh.
Uh-huh.
- I love this.
I've never even seen this
kind of detail before.
Originally, you wanted
lots and lots of flake.
Yeah, yeah.
But with the baby
blue, lots of flakes
just seemed a little too much.
So I gave it the proper sprinkle
of flake in the right places
to where it really catches
your eye rather than it
just being a disco ball.
I didn't necessarily
do patterns.
I didn't really do scallops.
I just kind of did both
a blend of the two.
- So Twinkletoe's up there.
- Yeah.
Dude, dude, that's
etched in the glass.
- Are you kidding me?
- That's not a sticker me
That's not a sticker.
That's etched.
Dude!
That is so sick.
I'm gonna get straight
up harassed in Atlanta.
[laughing]
- Yes, you will.
You will be harassed.
You are, you are.
I want you to see
under the hood.
You're gonna love this,
because everything
is like a factory Cadillac.
Wow.
Everything is original.
It smells like a new engine.
Absolutely.
Kevin, why don't you shoe him
some of the interior over here.
- Yeah.
- I'll drop the hood down.
Come check this.
[laughing] Yeah, man!
Yes.
Look at this man in this car.
You look so proper in this car.
Feeling good in there?
Oh, yeah.
- Sparkly enough for you?
- Oh, yeah.
[laughing]
There you go.
There you go, lean back.
Get that lean, baby!
Come on.
[laughing]
Amazing.
I'll hit the button, if
you guys will grab the trunk.
The 70 has a lot
of little things.
Whoa.
Bam!
Plenty of room
for all your stuff.
Amazing.
Thump.
This is just blowing
my mind completely.
You guys have done it again.
That's what we like to hear.
It's amazing.
This makes me so, so happy.
And in less than
10 years, right?
Yeah, you did it in
less than 10 years.
- Not bad.
- That's commendable.
[laughing]
Let's do this, man.
Let's go to the office, let's
get your paperwork done.
Yes, paperwork.
Twinkletoes is going home.
(SINGING) Twinkletoes.
[laughing]
You know, it's
always great help
a car lover get out of a jam.
And it's even cooler when
that car lover happens to be
a Grammy award winning rocker.
It just makes it better.
Is it OK if Ryan puts
it back in the garage?
You know what?
I'm gonna leave it right here.
- Yeah?
- Yeah, it's ready to go.
Let's just sit there and
look at it for a while, man.
Pull up a chair, crack a
cold one, stare at a car.
Absolutely.
That's what to do.